hi there today we'll look at
deberta decoding enhanced bert with
disentangled attention
by peng cheng shiadong liu jungfen gao
and waiju chen of microsoft
this paper is an improvement on bert the
language model and the
roberto variant of it specifically
it so it suggests two improvement namely
first is this disentangle attention
where they disentangle
positional information and content
information
of the individual tokens in the
attention mechanism
and the second improvement kind of
results from the first improvement
as this decoding enhanced decoder
i guess enhanced decoder where because
they only use
relative positional information in the
transformer part of the model
they have to re-feed the absolute
positional information at the end
which gives them another bit of
improvement all together with this they
reach
state of the art in various nlp tasks
and
this model the berta is now available in
hogging face
for you to download for all of your nlp
needs so we're going to go through the
paper
and look at the two improvements and
what they give
let's and see if that's relevant
as always if you like content like this
don't hesitate to
share it out to all of your friends and
leave a like
and a comment uh i still read all the
comments so
give me your opinion and please also
give me your opinions on the new
recording setup there should be a title
somewhere here
a picture somewhere here i absolutely
want to hear feedback because i
have no idea what i'm doing so yeah
all right let's dive in de berta or
diberta
or de berta i don't know i think it's d
berta because it's from decoding
enhanced
diverta is a new model architecture they
say here
we propose a new model architecture
deberta
decoding enhanced vert with disentangle
attention
that improves the burt and roberta
models using
two novel techniques the first is the
disentangled attention mechanism
where each word is represented using two
vectors that encode its
content and position respectively and
the attention weights
among the words are computed using
disentangled matrices on their contents
and relative positions
respectively okay we'll look at that
first
so what they mean is when you have
a when you have a multi-head attention
layer what we want to do is we want to
transform
one sequence of tokens of token
representations
into the next sequence of token
representations now usually
every token let's say these are our
tokens and this could be a sentence in a
language like i
am hungry and here is like a
this see this classification token
that we always add when we train bert
um every one of these tokens is
represented by a vector
this is a vector this is a vector it has
many entries
this is a vector some of the vectors are
thicker than others
i mean that's just this one just hasn't
eaten enough
um so every one of these tokens is
represented by
a vector and what a multi-head attention
layer does is it
it simply transforms this via means of
the attention mechanism
into a series of vectors again so we
we put in a series of vectors and we end
up with another
series of vectors if you want to know
what a multi-head attention does in
detail
please go look at my video attention
is all you need where that's explained
specifically it is a attention it is
sort of an information
routing algorithm that sees
that sees how information needs to be
routed from
tokens to tokens using queries
keys values and so on if you haven't
seen the video
it's a beautiful mechanism but i'm not
going to explain it again
right here i'm sorry all right
so in this um
what you usually do is you transform
vectors into vectors
and because of how the multi-head
attention mechanism works
the mechanism has no way to discern
where in a sentence for example a given
token
is so it cannot differentiate between
this sentence here
and the sentence am i hungry if it's
just multi-head attention
is just not possible for it because it
treats the
incoming sentence as like a bag of words
which is not the case in for example
a recurrent neural network so recurrent
neural network would go
one by one over these word
representations and
it has kind of a mechanism to to see
what a sequence is however multi-edition
doesn't so what people usually do is
they
augment these representations with
position
encodings so that's at the beginning
you know where you might ask where do
these vectors come from
the very f of course they come from the
last layer but the very first vectors
you put in come from a table
and these are your classic word vectors
so
at some at some point you have a big
table
and the big table has your entire
vocabulary
in it so every word in the language that
you consider so there's i
and there's m and there is u and there
is apple
and there is hungry and there is even
the cls token
all of them have a table entry and all
of them have a vector
associated with them now these vectors
are trainable so the neural network
can decide itself what goes into these
vectors
but every word has a fixed vector in
there
and in the very first layer because you
don't have a last layer to draw from
you simply look at what token it is you
go to the table
right here you retrieve this vector and
you put it here and that's your start
and then you transform up the layers of
course every time from the last layer
but at the beginning you have embeddings
now the same thing you do for positions
okay
so you also have a second table usually
and the original transformer paper by
the way these were fixed
vectors but nowadays i think
most of them are also trained so you
label the positions
so that's position that's position one
that's position two
three and four so for every position two
three four and maybe you have also five
and six there is a maximum length
but right now we consider sentences of
length
three with a cls token appended
so these are length four so every
position
also has a vector and i'm going to
actually draw these vectors
in this color so every position has a
vector
irrespective of what word there is okay
right now we just have vectors for words
irrespective of where they are
and we have vectors of positions
irrespective of what words there are
and what you do is same you look at
what position is here you go to the
table
you retrieve that embedding and you
somehow also put it here now i've made a
bit of a mess
here with this thing sorry
so how do you
now you have two vectors all of a sudden
per word so you have
one that is a position and you have one
that is the kind of the word itself that
represents the word itself
and the neural network it needs both in
order to understand the sentence right
if every word has these two vectors at
the beginning now it can understand
aha this is the word i that is at the
beginning of the sentence so it's
probably the subject
of a sentence however if the word m was
at the beginning
it could be oh it probably a question
because it
starts with a verb like am i hungry
okay and it can also evaluate the
relative distances of things to each
other and so on
so given this information the neural
network has all the tools it sort of
needs to understand that
sentence as a sequence now
what you have you have basically two
ways
of uh combining the two things first of
all you can concatenate them
which means that i'm gonna do it in this
you just put
no that's terrible you just put the
i'm not too skilled yet with this new
thing um
you put this on top here imagine this is
the same length and you just concatenate
the vector so now
the the vector is longer of course that
also increases your dimensionality
computational issues and so on so what a
lot of people do is they simply
you know line them up if they're the
same size and they add them together
element wise and you know in the worst
case
the neural network now can decide
because both of these are trained right
so the neural network can absolutely
decide that you know in the top part
here
it simply learns a bunch of zeros and
then the bottom part here it simply
learns a bunch of zeros here so
essentially
it's a concatenation that's the worst
case in the best case the neural network
can actually do some
kind of information combining already in
this
addition step down here okay
so the you you give both encodings to
the neural network as a single vector
right so what goes into the
multi-edition mechanism is a single
vector
this paper says that is not ideal
because the positions are too much mixed
with the um with the signal
of the content of the words and we'd
rather have this in a disentangled
representation
such that the network can sort of reason
about the words
in one line and it can reason about the
position
of the words in another line
so their goal is to disentangle these
two vectors and basically
design a new attention mechanism that
always
treats the content and the position
as separate things so the new attention
mechanism
they propose is right here of course
they're not they can't stay
separate right but um they
they can be disentangled through the
layers
so their new algorithm sort of is here
the way they obtain the attention matrix
is due to the following uh thing so
how do you usually obtain the attention
matrix
you have your input x here this is your
sequence
and you produce two values from it q
and k so these are matrices
so if x is a sequence
then every single sequence element emits
one
key which is a vector right one key
and then every single one also emits one
query
so like this like this and the key sort
of the key
is supposed to say what is in
what information is this token about
and the query is kind of supposed to say
what information
does it request from other tokens so now
you route the information
wherever the inner products line up for
example probably this
thing would go to would be routed here
and so on it's not a hard routing it's a
soft routing
so by transforming x by linear
transformations into
keys and queries you
obtain your attention matrix by
multiplying together
queries and keys such that you have
sort of the inner product between each
of these vectors
and this is quadratic and this is the
big bottleneck in transformers
but you have the inner product between
each of the two you get a giant matrix
and the giant matrix basically says how
much does token token2
attend to token3 that's the position 2
3 of that matrix and that's that seek
that element is going to be the inner
product
of the query of token 2
with the key of token three so that's
how you do the attention
matrix and these vectors right here
they if you do regular bird they always
have
they're always everything at the same
time so you feed your feed content
and position somewhere down the layers
you feed that in
you add it together and the network is
supposed to figure out itself how to use
these two pieces of information
this paper says no wait we can do better
what we can do is for us each sequence
element
it does not only produce one key and one
query
it actually we think it should be
contained
it should be a made up of two vectors
so each of these things has two
different uh two different components
one is this
kind of h component which is
uh the which is the content uh
content information and one is the p
component which is the positional
information
so here how should
how should token i attend
to token j they say well that is going
to be it's going to be the same thing
it's going to be the inner product
between the between
the this is the query
of token i and this is the key
of token j okay
however now the queries and keys are
made up of two
of two different parts one is the
content part one is the position part
and the position
as you can see maybe is j
condition on either position is going to
be a relative positioning
so if you have your sequence right here
what
each token would do is it would emit one
vector oh sorry
it would emit one vector that is
the content of the token
like before and then another vector
would come in
from the position so the same we did
at the beginning but now in each layer
this positional information comes in
irrespective of what work there is right
irrespective of what word is in the
position
the position gets an encoding right here
and then the interesting thing is we
don't add the two together
we treat them actually separately so
here the keys
are two vectors and the queries are also
two vectors so i'm just going to draw
one up here so
the query is going to be a vector and
the
query for the position is also going to
be a vector and that also it depends
only on the position
and not on the incoming signal okay
so now how do we route information
now we have four different routings
first we only consider dark blue dark
blue
so this is kind of the classic attention
right this
and this they match really well so that
goes here
uh that one probably doesn't go there
and so on but then we also so this is
what they call
content to content routing but then we
also have
content to position position to content
and position to position routing and
in all of these so for example in
content to position now i'm
i'm sure i'm gonna there's a 50 50
chance i'm going to mix this up
and i'm sure i'm going to but in content
to position what we're going to do is
we're going to
look at this vector right here which is
the content vector of the query
that is produced from the token right
the content is produced from the token
and we're going to attend to the
position
vector of the key so we're going to
attend to the light blue
things so essentially
the this part is like the classic
attention part it is
i am the word am i'm requesting
all informations from all the nouns in
the sentence because
i'm a verb and i would like to know who
are the nouns in the sentence
then the content to position
encodings is i am the verb
am i would like to know what is around
me the positions are
relative positions so i can request the
vector
for you know the plus one position of me
or the plus two so the word
can attend to its surroundings so given
that it's the word
m it might be particularly interesting
maybe it has already figured out
it's not a question right um
from the previous layers so it's
particularly interested in what's before
it
so because you know m actually it
probably isn't particularly interesting
because it's always going to be i
so actually maybe it's exactly a counter
example
where it wouldn't want information from
there but it can sort of attend
it can say i want to attend to things
after myself because i already have
figured out
that before me must be an i i want to
attend two things
after me like one position after me
what's right after me what's two words
after me and so on
position to content is exactly the
opposite
it is it is saying so the token can say
well i am in i am in uh i am
in position plus four
to you know what kind of information do
i want to send
to things that are for away from me
right irrespective of what the content
is so
here we simply consider what position is
the token
with respect to its neighbors and what
kind of information does it want to
aggregate from each of the words
it is a bit it's a bit weird right so it
says
it says like i i am in in position
a word that is two words after me
what kind of information do i want to
get from it
and since it's attending to content that
can be dependent
on um that can be dependent on what word
there is but not its position and then
position to position
is simply well what what kind of
information do i
in position you know three you want to
send to something in position
seven which would be useful but this is
relative position encoding which simply
means i am always
kind of in the middle and so this isn't
really helpful so they decide to
leave this away so we end up with the
three
different attention mechanisms so to say
we end up so there's this one there's
this one
and there's this one okay corresponding
to the three out of four different ways
we can comb
combine the dark blue and the light blue
keys and
queries now
you can see right here that's what they
do and their final attention matrix is
simply the addition
of all of those together so we construct
one
attention from like the classic
attention
we construct one attention that is
content to position
positioned to content
and we construct one that is positioned
to position but then we
leave it away because it's we deal with
relative positions so it will sort of be
the same
for every token and that's not
particularly helpful
reason i'm going to repeat it again the
h information
contains actual signal from the last
layer while the p
has no idea about the signal it simply
contains information about the position
of the tokens okay so you can decide to
send information to a word that's two
positions ahead of you
or to request information from where
that's three positions behind you
depending on what word
you yourself are okay so that's the
content to position and position to
content attention
these things are all added together and
that makes up the final attention matrix
so a final entry in the attention matrix
could
be influenced by multiple ones of them
it could say
you know i am the word i'm the word m
i'm in position two
i request a lot of information from
other nouns if any noun is here i want
information but i also want information
from
things that are one or two positions
ahead of me
so that that is and and you know
uh since i'm the word am and also since
i'm in position number two
i am very interested to
know what the subject of the sentence is
now we have
all of it okay
all right and the rest is is just
like classic attention okay
now you you simply so these
p and h matrices are obtained
by sorry the queries and the keys for
this are obtained
by uh linear transformation so you see
this is the incoming signal
you send it through a linear
transformation to obtain the queries
and you also send it through a linear in
transformation to obtain the keys
so the h is the same but the these
matrices here these are learned
weights to produce queries and keys
and then you multiply them together that
defines your attention matrix
uh you run that through a soft max to
make a distribution out of each row
and then you multiply together with the
values so this part here is kind of like
the routing table
and the values are the information to be
routed the values are
obtained from this input signal
as we said we're going to amend that by
so this over here is the classic key
queries keys and values
sorry that's too much the classic
queries keys and values and then we
augment that by two
new so there is the queries and the keys
for the position
and you can see that the difference here
is that again it's learned weights
but now there is this p thing right here
and the
p is positional encodings and that comes
exactly out of this table we saw up here
so the positional encodings come from
this
so and it's important to see that this
here is
h and this is the p values but this is
only h0
right h is actually transformed to h1
by the transformer the first layer to h2
by the second layer and so on the p
always stays the same
so you would feed the p into this layer
and you would feed it again into this
layer and you would feed it again
into this layer so you can see it's only
positional information
it's not content information and by
feeding the position each time and doing
this in this disentangled way
um the the
model can sort of keep the content and
position information separate
i actually think it it doesn't really
keep the information separate because
you know after layer one you certainly
have position information
in your age right you can see that from
from this path here from the actually
feeding position information into the
transformer layer
h1 is already going to be a conglomerate
of h0 which is pure content plus
the position somehow um this plus is not
a real addition
but somehow the information is
intermingled there and if we
weren't to feed in these things right
here
it would just be like the classic bird
right
what they criticize now by continuously
feeding the positional information
that is one advantage um you can
actually do that with bert you can just
add the position information each time
i'm not sure if that would
work super well but you can do that
just gives the model a bit more side
information to work with
and then by keeping it separate um
yeah as i said i'm not sure it's
actually separate
it's just that you keep feeding in
position information
layer after layer therefore giving the
model sort of
more information every time it makes a
transformation because otherwise it
would
have to carry through the position
information through all the layers just
from the very first layer
so in this mechanism you can see it's
true that the position encoding
is kept separate because it comes in
fresh every layer
but i don't i don't see that the content
the content certainly has position
information in it from the last layer
like i hope you can you can see that so
as i said they uh do relative position
encoding what does that mean
so that means that um
the position encoding depends
on where you look from so what i've
drawn at the beginning like this here
this isn't entirely correct you have to
look at each token individually so for
this middle token here for example
if the positions look like this they
look like negative 2 negative 1
0 1 2. and you would you'd have kind of
a table
not with absolute positions but you'd
actually have a table with negative 2
negative 1
0 1 plus 1 plus 2 and so on
and you would retrieve those vectors and
then you when you consider the next
vector
this one right here it would look
different
it would right this would be zero this
minus one minus two and so on
so they do two things first of all they
truncate at some point
uh they simply say well our context
window is two so instead of going
negative three here
we simply keep it at negative 2. so
everything beyond negative 2
gets also the vector for negative 2. so
that vector here
is going to be just plugged into here
and into here for this token right and
for this token for the previous token it
is only going to be plugged here and if
and nowhere else
there are ways to efficiently implement
this and that's this algorithm
right here don't want to go too much
into it but just so
you're aware you don't have to consider
each token
really individually during it attention
that would be
prohibitively expensive so you can do
one big matrix multiply and then sort of
pick and choose together from your
from the matrix that results especially
with this truncation
this is this algorithm so they call it
efficient implementation
all right so that is this position
position enhanced or disentangled
information why is it disentangled again
because in every layer they have a side
input this this piece right here is the
side input
that they sort of feed on top
of this information and they
specifically construct
the attention matrix out of the three
things right
it's almost like two contributions the
one contribution is
hey let's feed in position information
in each layer and
i think that has been tried before
that's pretty simple but then the second
thing is that
we don't we don't simply add the two
vectors
when we input it into the attention but
we're going to construct basically three
attention matrices
um and then add those together
once we determine the inner products
between each of those
okay so this is one of the improvements
and that already helps a lot but then
they run into a problem and this is not
necessarily a problem with their
method but this is a problem in general
when you use relative positioning
codings
so they say given a sentence a new store
opened beside a new mall right that's a
sentence
the words store and mall uh
are mass so let's say you do this mask
language model pre-training right you
mask out the words
store and mole and you ask the model to
reconstruct them
using only the local context eg relative
position and surrounding words
is insufficient for the model to
distinguish store and maul in this
sentence since both follow the word new
with the same relative positions so from
the word
new you know relatively it's always plus
one oopsie it's plus one
to this word so the model cannot
distinguish the two
so there is a need for absolute position
encodings because if you had absolute
position in codings you could maybe make
sense though
um you know since i mean you could you
could figure out like store is probably
kind of a smaller thing and
mall is kind of a bigger thing so um
it's more likely that the store opened
beside the new mall
then the mall opened beside the new
store okay
so that so that means we need
absolute position encodings or something
like this right
and especially we could have relative
position encodings but if this is a very
long sentence and we truncate them
somewhere
again these two things are not in range
of one another
and they're not gonna know how far you
know they are apart and
each each one by itself is just plus one
apart
so how do we solve the problem
we feed in absolute positioning coatings
however
that's exactly what they criticize they
say no relative position encodings are
much better than absolute
for learning and that's kind of the same
reasoning why a convolution is better
than a fully connected layer
because you kind of slide the
transformation over and it's simply
data relative to each other so relative
positioning makes a lot of sense if
when every word can do computation not
based on
where exactly it is in the sentence but
how it is in relation to other words
otherwise
if you have absolute position in codings
what you would have to do is
you would have to say well if i'm the
word m and i'm in position two
i need to learn to attend to position
three however if i'm the word m and i'm
in position three i need to learn to
attend to position four
and if i'm in position four i need to
learn to attend in position five these
are all different things you need to
learn
however if you have relative encoding um
what you can do is you can simply say i
want to attend to the word that's right
after me
easy but we do need absolute position
encoding for some things
namely disambiguate between tasks like
this so they feed in absolute position
information
but instead of doing it at the beginning
they do it at the end so at the
beginning we have
the word vectors right they go in here
and then we have position information
one two three four
five we have that at every single
layer of the transformer we feed it in
again and again
and again we feed in the same p vectors
okay they have different different of
these
sorry of these transformations in each
layer so the
actual transformation that makes the
keys and the values
sorry the keys and the queries of the
position information are different but
the vectors are the same every time
and then at the very top so these are p
relative so this is sorry
yeah i mixed up this is the this is this
negative 2 negative 1
0 1 2 for the middle token
and then at the end we're going to feed
in
absolute position encodings so here we
have you know your
let's start at one let's be good matlab
people
here we have one two three four five
that we're going to now combine
with the vectors that come out of here
so the reasoning is
they say there are two methods of there
are two methods of incorporating
absolute position
the burp model incorporates absolute
position in the input layer
in dberta we incorporate them right
after all the transformer layers
but before the softmax layer for masked
token prediction
as shown in figure two i've looked at
figure two it's
it's not really helpful honestly um so
that is this figure in the appendix
where they they say
okay so in the bert late in the birth
you have the
absolute position encoding somewhere
down here it goes through all the
transformer layers
and then you have this classification
layer at the top that does the
language model decoding however in their
model
what you'd have is you have all the
transformer layers here
down here and then you have the absolute
position encodings that come
in through the side here and
kind of the last transformer layer now
has access to these absolute layers or
the last n
i think n in their case is two or one
one or two so in the last layer or the
last layers
now the transformer has access to the
absolute positions
and before it's just relative position
at each step
and they reason that that helps because
the transformer part learns
to deal with relative positions
okay in this way they say here d
berta captures the relative positions in
all the transformer layers and only uses
the absolute position as complementary
information when decoding
the masked words thus we call the
berta's decoding component and enhanced
masked
decoder and they compare the two
and they observe that emd works much
better
so feeding absolute positions at the end
works better than feeding him at the
beginning okay
we conjecture that the early
incorporation of absolute positions used
by bird might undesirably hamper the
model from learning sufficient
information of relative position
in addition emd also enables us to
introduce other useful information that
is in two positions the yada yada we
leave it for future
so they say you could also feed in other
information i guess that's the case in
every single neural network ever um
yeah but the point is they feed in the
absolute position at the end
and their conjecture so i'm not sure i'm
not a fan of this
i'm here you know this is this is like
saying
okay if we only feed it in at the end
right here this is position absolute
then we sort of limit the model like
right now the model has the same
information
as it had before as if we were to feed
it at the
beginning but we sort of limit
it to only one layer of transformation
so all it can do is sort of
have kind of a little linear
transformation in
in there and yeah and so if we don't
feed that in here
whereas we do feed it in the model can
use it
or any way it wants and
that's just not a good enough reason for
me so
i think you know regularization has its
place
bottleneck layer has its place and so on
restricting the capacity and so on but
i'm not a fan of hampering the model in
this way kind of restricting it
and i you know just because it makes
your your number better
there's not really a reason why the same
information
should be worse if you give the model
more steps to compute to compute with
you know if you feed it in at the
beginning technically if you train the
model correctly it should learn to use
that
information in at least as good a way
as if you feed it in at the end right at
least
that tells me that the model that we
haven't really figured out how to train
these models correctly yet
with regards to positional encodings and
again i'm not a fan of simply saying
well we only feed it in
at the end because then the question
immediately is well how many layers at
the end how many layers at the beginning
or when you know when is it too pop it's
it's just
yeah i don't think it's it's it makes a
lot of sense
to simply give the model information but
not let it do
its best with that information unless
you have a specific
kind of reasoning why this is just not
good enough
for me here um not a criticism
of the you know obviously it's better
like they observe
like you know ever all the in all the
information
sorry all the arguments can be
invalidated by but it's better
right that's deep learning uh so yeah
all
respect for them for trying it out and
actually realizing it's better
pretty cool so they also do uh scale
invariant fine tuning where
if they fine tune which is where you
take kind of this this model you trained
with mask language modeling and then you
fine tune it to
nlp tasks they have a bunch of tricks
there like virtual adversarial training
and
normalizing the uh embeddings before
they do that and that apparently helps a
lot
but they also say they leave the
comprehensive study of this for future
work
for now they just want to get the good
number which is understandable
because you get published um
all right so here you can see
uh actually we can we can skip most of
the tables they are better
they are better they are better they are
better in language modeling too which is
interesting so you
they can do kind of bird style denoising
but
in classification you can also do
actually all the regressive
language model uh which is pretty cool
so here they do an ablation study
of the different components where they
remove this
enhance the decoder and one time they
remove the
condition content to position encodings
uh sorry attention mechanism and one
time they reduce
the position to content tension
mechanism and
in the table it is sort of a wash it
depends on the task of how you look
at but each of the components here
gets you some kind of a benefit or
a hit when you take it away so um
yeah it's not really clear that one of
the components gives you all the boost
the combination of them is obviously the
best
and it's really cool when papers do
these kinds of ablations rather than
just
throw a bunch of stuff at you and you
it's on you to figure out
which of that stuff is important
um they compare it to roberta
in terms of training of accuracy
after training so how much do you need
pre-training
for a fine tuning and the deeper to as
you can see in these graphs outperforms
robert
so potentially you need less
pre-training steps
to reach the same accuracy in
a fine-tuning task which is cool also
means that if you train for longer
you reach or if you train for the same
amount of time you reach a higher
accuracy
and now for you know their big thing
they build
they scale it up and they have a bunch
of um tricks
here and you know pretty cool they scale
it up i just want to highlight
one trick we optimize the model
architecture as well
first we share the projection matrices
of relative position embeddings
okay so they share the projection
matrices of the relative position
embeddings
with each other okay so they share
the position matrices with the content
matrices
so now instead of for example so here is
the query
of the content the key of the content
here is the query
of the projection and the key of the
sorry position position
my battery is soon over i have to speed
up um
so the content
right here and the position right here
give rise to these matrices
by means of these help of these learned
weights right
so here is wc here is w
sorry w k c w k
uh c sorry w
that's the matrix that generates the
queries from the content
that generates the keys from the content
the matrix that generates
the queries from the position and the
matrix that generates the
keys from the position so
if you now share you now want to share
this
and that and also you want to share this
and that
so if and at the end they are added
right
so you multiply these things and then
they are added
and in my mind honestly
what what that results in because
before let's just
let's just see so before you had
something like
if you if we simply multiply query times
key transposed
for the context site that would give you
sort of context
w q and now we share them
so we don't care about c and p anymore
w k transposed k transposed
and oh sorry um
of course context is this transposed and
now we add them
to something else and let's just say we
have these position
two position encodings that they leave
away but you know we're gonna consider
them because it's easiest so it's
position w q w
k uh yeah transposed
position transposed you know if these
matrices are
shared this simply ends up to be being
the addition of the position
and content times these two matrices
times the
again this so and this is just like the
old school attention mechanism now i see
there's these cross terms and maybe they
influence something
but it gets closer and closer uh back to
the old mechanism where you simply add
the
encodings and don't consider them in a
in a disentangled way right if you do
if you decent if you like share the
matrices of the disentangled
representations
it simply refers back to as if you were
to feed the position
in each layer of a traditional
transformer
so yeah i'm not sure how much really the
disentanglement
is super important or whether or not
it's just
you know more important that this
positional information is actually
available
at each step but you know i might be
wrong here with the cross terms
i haven't actually looked entirely at
that
um yeah so that's the paper they have
kind of a discussion
depiction of attention matrices down
here where they show that their model
you know does some does something kind
of
different from other models in terms of
where it attends it has less of these
global attention
patterns like roberta has right here
um except for the very first one which
is the cls vector which makes sense
and otherwise has a rather diagonal
attention matrix so that's
it's pretty sensible though you can also
make the case that sometimes there are
just really important words
in a sentence that everything should
attend to
i don't know but it is state of the art
and
it is a cool algorithm and is worth
considering if
you build your next model alright with
that
i thank you for listening subscribe if
you haven't i'll see you next time bye